Another piece of information that the
cache maintains about each of the blocks
it has is the so-called valid bit.
If we look at the cache with
four blocks of data and
the tag that tells us which block
we have in each of the lines,
the question is, what happens
when we turn on the processor?
At that time the cache
contains no useful data.
But the data will have some bits here.
Even if all of the bits are zero,
we need to know that whatever address we
produce, it doesn't match
any of these blocks here, so
that we need to access memory and
bring the actual data into the cache.
We do this by matching the tag.
But what does the tag initially have?
If the tag initially
just has all zeroes,
what if we're accessing address
like this where it might
happen that this address actually has
a tag bit that correspond to zero?
In that case the initial
tag would match this and
we would be accessing this
garbage data in the cache.
Which hasn't been brought from memory,
so we're really accessing something
that is not equal to what
we should be accessing.
Note that any possible value for
the tag might match the tag
of an actual address.
So, it is not that it is
wrong to initialize to 0,
it's that any particular initial value
here, would produce the same problem.
So what we do, is we add an additional
bit of state to the cache for each line.
That tells us whether the tag and
the data are valid.
Initially, the valid bits need to be
set to 0, which means that if our tag
matches the address but the valid bit
is 0, we treat that as not a hit.
So the hit condition is really
the tag matches our block number and
the valid bit is set to one.
By setting the valid
bits to zero initially,
we make sure that none of these can
hit until real data is brought in.
And thus, we also remove the problem
of initializing the data and the tag.
We can leave anything here.
So these don't need to be zeroed out
as long as the valid bit is set to
zero correctly.
So when we boot up the processor,
we set all the valid bits to zero.
And then,
when we bring stuff from memory,
put the data here, set the tag to
correspond to the block's number.
And at that time,
we also set the valid bit to one.